the church is brought to you by on
it.com
for the best supplements period go to
honor.com right now and press in church
and get 10 percent off
the church is also brought to you by
blue apron blue apron is the number one
fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country
you could cook meals in 30 minutes or
less
this week's menus on warm smoked trout
spiced zucchini
locked
enchiladas
style vegetable tostadas with summer
squash and the list is endless you
understand me do me a favor right now go
to blueapron.com
joey and you're going to get your first
three meals for free with free shipping
by going to blueapron.com
joey i'm gonna get you your first three
meals for free with
free shipping the podcast is also
brought to you by lyft
let me explain something to you when you
drive
for the right ride sharing app every
trip can feel like a walk in the park
with lyft you can pick your own hours
and work when you want lyft can make
driving the best job in the world so do
me a favor join the number one ride
sharing company that believes in
treating its people right
go to lyft.com
joey today and we'll get you a 500 new
driver bonus that's lift.com
joey
today
and limited time
terms applied but i'll get you 500 new
bonus ride today
kick this mule lee
oh [ __ ]
it's memorial day [ __ ] and uncle joey
and his little jewish cousin showed up
ain't that a [ __ ]
we showed up with reefer barbecue
[ __ ] everything
and here we are
out of respect for greg allman
as good as it gets in my [ __ ] world
dirty
balls
that's what the church is all about
[ __ ] here we go
kick it lee i want the speakers
to light themselves on fire
two drummers two guitarists that were
savages
and this [ __ ] smooth [ __ ]
here we go
stop it
kick that [ __ ] mule
happy monday [ __ ] uncle joey here we
showed up because you're gonna need us
the most on a [ __ ] monday everybody
else is grilling and doing what the [ __ ]
they're doing we showed up to have a
little party here all right pete greg
allman you know what man it's crazy
because
you don't even finish more than one guy
and somebody else [ __ ] dies on you
it's been like that for the last [ __ ]
year you know i'm saying like you're
still in the heat over [ __ ] prince
and this guy dies and mary tyler moore
dies
and this is your childhood these are the
people you know when i came from cuba i
watched mary tyler moore every [ __ ]
day on tv so when she died a couple
weeks ago did i shed a deer i mean i i
didn't send flowers or anything but i
was kind of upset because
you [ __ ] know him well at least you
think you know him you know you've been
watching him chris cornell killed me
last week guys i can't even tell you the
first
like couple days later when i put his
music on in my office
and i'm doing [ __ ] and i'm like jesus
you know this is amazing this guy's gone
and now greg orman i mean he was 69 you
know uh
i'm not sure if he was touring i know he
was in no folks home or something but
these are the guys that [ __ ] uh
you know especially this guy
he let me know it was all right you know
when i listen to the older brothers i
feel like stabbing somebody i feel like
uh
like i'm [ __ ] dangerous myself
but anyway it's i'm great to be here
lisa what's happening i'd have i had a
great weekend i went to the to a minor
league baseball game they made fun of me
for i did something weird today i went
swimming i haven't like i took swimming
classes as a kid and i know i physically
know how to swim
but i could only do like one length at a
time and i was out of breath
i i ended up doing five
total but it took me like 30 minutes i'd
take breaks and my like my legs almost
collapsed in the pool i've never been
that sore immediately during a workout
you know with swimming it's all form and
that's what people don't realize with
everything
when you really come to think about it
it's so much for them but swimming like
lift like power lifting
it's all a form where you're gonna hurt
yourself i always tell people if you get
into powerlifting or kettlebells
do it the first time with somebody who
really knows them and could watch you so
you don't hurt yourself because once you
hurt yourself with those
with swimming i did the same thing
i was gonna get locked up i wanted to be
in the best shape i could be in right
and i went to a [ __ ] swimming class
and i thought i knew what i knew and i
didn't know dick
and it took like six weeks to re-teach
me how your legs have to be straight
your hips have to be up a little bit
because your legs have to be on top of
the wall these are all things that
require strength
and you have to develop that strength
over time that's not going to happen in
one day i have the same weakness on the
front my left doesn't barely goes up my
right goes up like a champ but my left
hand
you have to get a kickboard a paddle
board and hold on to it okay and just do
20 minutes of kicking
i was thinking about that just in the
lane up and down the line that's it
that's what they're going to give you in
that class for the first two weeks
they're just going to kick kick for 20
and then put the [ __ ] buoy between
your legs and pull
and pull and pull and pull and do all
this [ __ ] and work on the mechanics
because the mechanics of the swim when
you raise your right hand it's not that
you raise your head and toughen your
neck muscles
that's not what they want you to do they
want you to stay loose in the water
okay so as you're swimming
boom
the left goes over but when the right
goes over you turn with the right not
pick up
but turn with the right
and then exhale as you go in ex you have
two exhales and then pull up again and
that's all mechanics that you have to
work it's uh so you have to work your
upper body right and then you have to
work your lower body and then put them
together and the breathing and the
breathing and like that's that's like
that was one of your main reasons for
starting jiu-jitsu and like i'm just
realizing now with everything every
workout that i've ever done breathing
has always been an issue breathing
controls everything dr believes spoke
about it boss rooting speaks about it
alberto crane speaks about it higgin
machado speaks about it the other uh the
gracie speaks about it with the
with the
the kind of yoga with the drum that the
the santa claus looking [ __ ]
teaches the flame of death the the the
breath of death and all that stuff
they all talk about how breathing
controls everything because when you get
scared right away your breathing goes up
and you can't control your breathing
if you control your breathing you
control everything and that's what i
wanted to force myself to do
when i walked in those doors well i
found out i had the deficiency
and it really bothered me
so i wanted to work on that how to get
the most out of each breath when i do
the drill classes over there right i
usually
work on my breathing like each movement
i think about it i don't just drill
i move to how i want to breathe
so i practice it do you is there like a
breathing technique like when you move a
limb do you breathe a certain way you
breathe you hip escape you know a
certain thing so i always
work on my breathing to get the most out
of my breathing so my body gets used to
it
very breathing breathing is everything
and with swimming your body has to be
non-muscular your body has to be soft
because the harder your body is
the harder it is going to be to breathe
like anything else
so if your shoulders are tight
it's going to be hard to breathe so your
body has to really be like spaghetti if
you look at the good swimmers sit there
and look at the good swimmers that go
back and forth
they're not even breathing heavy
because their muscles are very relaxed
you don't think they're doing anything
but they're actually pulling their
technique is so good you know when you
do a breath stroke like this one here
when your hand goes down it goes down
like a missile okay your hands just not
going down your hands going in like a
missile and you're pulling that water so
when you're going down
look how you your water goes look how
your hand goes and i'm sure i'm not
doing that you're pushing so all these
little things but that all comes from
practice right you can't just watch that
on tv and jump in the [ __ ] water and
then they teach you the mechanics of it
and then you'll see how your oxygen
doubles in the pool
once you get over that hurdle you'll go
holy [ __ ]
my cardio no no no you just cleaned up
all the fat off the [ __ ] steak
you just took all the fat of movement
you were wasting movement
that's all swimming is
and then using i guess your power so you
don't have to do as many strokes
yeah yeah yeah yeah so
you're cupping your hand a certain way
so when your hand
goes into the water
it's actually going through the water
and as you're going you're pulling
so all those movements are working
together at the same time your feet
are kicking
your feet are kicking the whole time
this is wire swimming is two parts
this is why they'll break it down into
two parts for you they'll break it down
to the lower part
where you just go in and pull just pull
for [ __ ] 20 minutes
for the first week if they know anything
about anything they'll just have you
hold on to the wall
and kick for a whole week for a whole
[ __ ] week just so you learn how to
float
your body will automatically teach
itself how to float above
so your hips will be a certain way so
you'll kick naturally
because that's going to be the clinch
you'll see that all of a sudden your ass
for you to kick
naturally how they want you to kick your
knees have to be slightly bent
just slightly
but the whole time you're kicking
and it's slightly bent you're not
splashing
you're kicking big difference
you're not going
right yes a lot of people do that
okay that's their style you know you're
just moving through the water when you
see a shark move one of those things
they're not moving with all this water
against water
they're moving with the water and that's
what you become you become like you're
moving with the water
are there yeah exactly especially
because i'm so big it's hard to move
that much
and all i kept thinking about was how
amazing
like when you hear about like the ds
brothers who do triathlons where they
have to run bike and swim
i can't even it's tremendous
before i got locked up let me tell you
something when i got sentenced
they asked to see if i could they asked
to see if i could get a continuance if i
could stay out a few days
and the main thing i was going to do was
go apologize to that swim teacher
because i just stopped going to a class
the day i got sentenced
i went to that class
about nine months before i got sentenced
wow and i went to that class in the
winter
like i joined that class like in august
and i stuck it out
all through the [ __ ] winter when it
snowed i would still go how many days a
week were you swimming three wow mondays
wednesdays and fridays
and then that summer that i got
sentenced august 15th but that july i
did my first buy
athlete event
no way i had to ride a bicycle for two
miles which is nothing right and had to
swim for a mile and i can't lie that i
didn't finish the mile swim
that's cool i don't know i can't it was
my first one so i wasn't really prepared
for it i didn't know you had a i didn't
know the nutrition part of it
just nutrition part of it i got knots in
my stomach and
that's it you know but it was
interesting i didn't finish it but it
was interesting
yeah i can't i don't even know
like i i could barely do a length i
don't even know what a mile that took
nine months to accomplish i was always
riding my bike my ex-wife had a
what do you call those big bikes with
the tires a beach mountain bike oh yeah
beachcomber i always had a beach combat
for some reason
and i always rode it to hertz and back
they had they really had a bike trail
that you had to obey and it was off the
car lane
so i didn't mind riding my bicycle to
hurting back there
because it was not on the street and
you'd ride it even in the snow oh on the
snow they picked me up oh okay they
picked me up jesus
that's uh
yeah so i'm just having fun doing it
there's no i'm just trying to do
different things
we're talking about you know
how
it took me 50 [ __ ] years to learn
this but
everybody's body is different and
everything works differently for
everybody
yoga might not work for you but it works
for me pilates might work for you you
know that's what's great about this
that's why i love groupon
because if you're interested in
something
you could always just go to groupon for
30 bucks
you spend 30 bucks on beers
easily yeah you know what's 30 bucks on
you won't try it
try the [ __ ] place if it doesn't work
for you move the [ __ ] on
what have you tried have you tried to
look at that and i know you did some
jujitsu's on there from groupon i did a
couple jiu jitsu's i went to
a cupping thing when dr amy was out of
the country
i went to work i took a cupping from
there no needles just cupping
what does that do i've seen that being
is good for your blood like it moves
your blood to your circulation
yeah i keep seeing everyone doing that
the tape and then uh i did something
else i got my toenail
burnt from whatever well you get the
[ __ ] uh you get the blowtorch to kill
the fungus in your nail
up in sherman oaks i got it i got it
through there for christmas
i showed my wife and she got it for me i
got a lot of stuff from groupon
a lot of stuff you know i can't remember
i got that one the first time i went to
hegan i i got it from groupon
it was like 10 sessions for 30 bucks he
wants [ __ ]
he wants like 250 a class
right oh yeah so i got a groupon i don't
give a [ __ ] i have no shame
no no [ __ ] no no that's what it's for
for people to try your thing you put it
on there and let me tell you something
they have restaurants on there
they got a ton of stuff on there tons
you could go on groupon for [ __ ]
hours if you wanted there's actually a
thing it's funny that you said
restaurants this thing like some girl's
like oh i won't i don't like it when i
won't go on a date with a guy if he
brings like a groupon to a restaurant i
can't imagine well i would never take a
date to a groupon anyway i'm talking
about if you and me are going to go eat
something
i'll go on groupon and go what the [ __ ]
you have you been there lean no me
neither all my friends say is good but
it's expensive and i got a groupon if
you go tuesday and thursday between six
and eight
that means they're dead that means they
want you in there right but you wouldn't
do it for a date
why not no because you don't wanna you
know you wanna look like you're [ __ ]
uh
you're not a cheap [ __ ]
there's little things that people do
that make you look like a chief [ __ ]
that'll drive a woman crazy a woman
wants security and here you want to play
it cheap under security
in the beginning
there's no cheapness and security in the
beginning in the beginning if the tab is
20 you're leaving a 10 tip
because you're trying to impress this
woman
or even a five dollar tip
you know it shows that you care it shows
that
you're cool with women
i'm a big tipper but i got like when i
was broke yeah i don't know i don't i
don't i guess i didn't see a problem
with it
you don't want to take a [ __ ] groupon
on your first [ __ ] date or your first
two dates yeah maybe not the first day
that i could unless you say it tied at
the table you know what man i've been
saying and then crack a joke like well
i've been single for so long i've been
eating groupon dinners and she's like oh
my god so have i maybe we should get a
groupon for two yes let's do it and beat
the system okay
now you found yourself a half a mutt
just like you
that's going to go out and torment
[ __ ] waiters because even if you get
a groupon at a restaurant right i always
leave the tip to make up the difference
oh and like what it would have cost yeah
like you try to leave the tip to make up
the difference
yeah that's why i always feel bad for
like denny's waiters
because that most the tip is gonna be
four or five dollars
so i have no idea how they make money
denny's let me tell you something
those waiters at denny's over here up
the corner right
have you been how many times have you
been in that denny's
20 times okay and one thing you'll
notice that it's all the same waiters
yeah in the last five years that you've
been going in there to be honest with
you six of those waiters have been there
longer than 10 years you know wildly
they make money there
they make a ton of money over there you
think so i know so
my friend jesse works over there he's
been there for years
he goes to more laker games
in one season that you and i have been
here how do you think he does on a
waiter's salary
they get paid at denny's they make they
get tips
plus it's high [ __ ] volume
i guess it's high volume a lot of work a
lot of work but they make bank over
there the one spanish girl with all the
teeth
she's been there 20 years the the chubby
japanese girl that's very sweet she's
been there for 20 years jesse's been
there for like 11.
it's a [ __ ] really weird thing
they went there they put their [ __ ]
sunglasses on their eye shades and they
blocked out all the [ __ ]
and they outlasted all the [ __ ]
people who went
through that you know i went to buy a
car last week and i went to subaru
and i brought my car up there and i
traded it in the lease and i got
the new crossfit whatever the [ __ ] it's
called i got a little back now to put my
daughter's toys back there i can put my
jiu-jitsu bag and then it doesn't leak i
don't have to put it in the back seat
and it smells
smelly or whatever
but while i was at the subaru place
[ __ ] i forgot what i was gonna tell you
yeah just uh loyalty i think customer
like a relationship
oh what the [ __ ] are we talking about
here
i went over to the subaru place
and it's my sick car
that i've gotten from them so it's a
real [ __ ] fast deal
like it's really fast but when i was
sitting there
jesus christ i got to stop smoking pot
with you
i'm a bad influence i'm sorry jesus
christ i hate this [ __ ] when you're mine
and the thoughts right there and all of
a sudden you
you you you look up and the thought just
[ __ ] disappears you know what i'm
saying i deal with it three times a day
with this stuff really it just goes
immediately with weed it's amazing how
it can be there for eight minutes and
then as soon as you want to say it's
gone
the other i was thinking of a joke in
the middle of night i went to write and
i [ __ ] forgot
from my bedroom to the office i forgot
the [ __ ] joke i sat in the hallway
for 10 minutes and shocked
i go i remember all the dumb [ __ ] in my
life
but i can't remember a good joke i read
in the fun and i wrote it took the mask
off
ushered it to myself three [ __ ]
times walked into the [ __ ] living
room showing my sneakers down and i go
damn i gotta move these things because i
don't want the baby to fall on them oh
no by the time i got to the [ __ ]
office i forgot the goddamn joke
[ __ ] [ __ ] was right do
you have to keep a pad in your bedroom
now or something well i got no lights in
there so i can't turn the [ __ ] light
on and wake my wife up and tell her hold
on one sec
i just thought of a [ __ ] stupid joke
or some [ __ ] like that cause she
wouldn't uh wouldn't fly no she wouldn't
[ __ ] fly
that makes sense so anyways it's a
subaru huh subaru i like it it's a great
car i'm happy i got it uh
i [ __ ] i forgot what the [ __ ] the
trainer thought was all together okay
you know i was thinking about when i
started selling cars like the the girl
who gave me the car and [ __ ] like that
there's times i'm like [ __ ] comedy [ __ ]
the podcast i'm gonna quit all this [ __ ]
and get a job selling subarus and i'm
like i better rethink that [ __ ] you know
they sell cars up there but it's not
what it used to people come in there
they know the prices they know the
homework
the the consumer is [ __ ] educated
than ever now with the internet
if the if people are smart they go on
the internet and get the payments they
want with the down payment i mean it's a
completely different game
so you have to sell volume also
you know the only thing that you make
money with is the used car because
a used car is what you'll pay for it
that's pretty much the basic with the
used car oh that's what i'll make you
pay for it that's why we're used cars
there's no addendum
there's always there's always four
thousand dollars in that price when we
tag
if you really think about it you could
really rock with a used car but
if a dealer is good they'll take a used
car they'll buy it over book because
it's clean then they'll put 500 into the
car to make it look brand new
so they've got some money in the [ __ ]
car sometimes so you really never know
it was in i was
shocked just as someone buying a car
that there's really not like a price
difference between used and new now it
just depends on what level you want to
go i've been on some lots where they
used cars with more expensive than the
new car
how does that happen because they have
to put a profit on it
and the people don't even look but
they'll say you know what it's 17 no
let's say there's a new
let's say there's a new
nissan something for 15 99 sticker i've
been to used car lots with that same car
a year earlier
it's like the model from the year before
that was a demo right and now they're
asking a thousand dollars more than that
car
because that's how they trick you
they say you see we had to pay more for
this one blah blah blah then they'll get
you to get can you imagine if somebody
comes in and pays 59.99 for that car the
year before
do you follow me so there's a lot of
profit in that car they stole that car
it's a demo
it's got miles on it and the whole god
damn thing
okay
so so is it like is it a scam really
because like it's not a scam it's just a
psychological move
like i went to like a scummy
well used car dealer my first car it was
like a
an abandoned lot with a trailer in it
and my car it was terrible as a two
thousand dollar car oh yeah buy here pay
here yeah exactly you have to show up
every friday and make a payment and [ __ ]
and hopefully they won't take your car
back
no i just paid it all in cash you know
what man salesman that those call outs
make a lot of money
i used to make a lot of money i worked
at one of those i got fired after three
weeks
but those three weeks i was there i made
like [ __ ] four grand or something
jesus have you seen that video that i
don't know where it is it's this black
guy who's running a card a lot but it's
like all beaters cars he's like i don't
want to hear about the radiator in three
weeks i don't care about this like it's
just your body just listen you're buying
a car
some people want to call for 800.
we think 800 hours gets you in a car get
your [ __ ] two seats a broken glass
and a headlight with [ __ ] tape on it
but that's what you can afford and
that's what you need you just need a car
to get you back and forth
when i first started comedy on the
triple runs
i got myself a datsun b210
with air conditioning and amf and
cassette
i don't need power windows i don't even
know that [ __ ]
i just need four tires and four brakes
isn't that the one that the body split
in half though
a couple times a couple of things happen
to that car
guess that's what happens
how have fun how much fun do you have
driving all over the country
i mean i know you were working and i
know you were probably broke but it just
seems like so like so much fun just to
get to like drive around the country
we talked about this on the show a few
weeks ago i'm very fortunate
that i got to know every nook and cranny
you have no idea when you drive
70 of it
like you figure
you really get to see the country you
get to see different people
you get to eat different [ __ ] foods
sounds like just god-awful and some that
are just tremendous
for dirt cheap you get to meet
personalities you know in different
places
i've been to army bases i think it was
fantastic
do i remember
90 percent of the people i met no
no there's times i think of certain
people that i've met and i go i wonder
where the [ __ ] they are now you know
and those 20 those those
from uh
94
to you know
98 that it was an adventure comedy i
look at it now and i make outlines to
write the book and [ __ ]
and i'm like i'm pretty [ __ ] weird
how i stuck it out those years
you don't think most comics would stick
being on the road for four straight
years out
it wasn't that i was on the road
i had nothing to do with the road it was
what i was doing while i was on the road
what i was going through
the divorce
being homeless being in prison i was in
jail not prison i was in county jail in
seattle for a month
that pissed off a few people
you know that made a few people stop
hanging out with me a few people stopped
booking me as a comedian you know most
people would have given up and i'm just
like i don't give a [ __ ]
it's just a bump in the room i knew
other comics that had their problems
you know i knew a lot of other comics
that had problems also and
that made me feel like i was all right
like i wasn't you know at that time it
wasn't like today there's no comics or
problems
there's nobody who's got an alcoholism
problem there's nobody you read about in
the paper anymore that gets arrested
that there's nothing like that
audie lang got arrested a few weeks ago
but that's no before that he had been
fined for years
i'm talking about you know
when i got into a comedy
there was five guys on the road
that every week you wouldn't know if
they were going to show up or not
really and they didn't get booked yeah
they were selling tickets
but they were drunks
or druggies or both
you know you didn't know these guys you
know you knew if they were going to show
up thursday but if they go out thursday
night and get [ __ ] up you didn't know
there was gonna be a show on friday
there was five or six of those good
[ __ ] guys and i would feature for
some of them
and i would be on that party train with
them you know what i'm saying i knew
what they were doing and they knew what
i was doing
did you have like someone who put you
through training or were you already
you you're i don't know was your taunts
already through the roof
like when you started like really
touring with comedy like did someone was
there one comic who would do more coke
with you or i don't know
you know
if you sit down
and i'm telling you people this just so
you know and so you know me
there's not a lot of people that cook
with me those days
because i didn't like doing it out
by that time you were already doing at
home i was going home
i go home i do two bumps
maybe a bump if you were driving
and i'd keep it cool so i got home
you know i got home i got high with tom
rhodes a few times in houston until late
in the middle of the night i you know
i got high at coaching horses a couple
nights with josh wolfe josh wolf and i
you know josh wolfe saw me in my worst
situations
you know he saw me a couple times at six
in the morning and [ __ ] like that
but uh
headliners i would get it with them do a
bump with them and then they would go
that way and i would go mine
[ __ ] was that was it lonely or you just
prefer no that's how i preferred it
i didn't want to go out around 10 people
anyway because i couldn't take the music
doing the coke talking to people
listening you got cottonmouth people
want to ask you questions
people want to get political there was a
phase with that and there was something
like even houston like i i used to go to
houston texas
and just go crazy for two weeks
like if i was gonna die i would have
died in houston
i would have died in beaumont i would
have died in miami
i would have died in austin there was a
lot of cities i went to purposely with
the intent to get high
not even on that like the comedy is a
crazy thing here's the craziest thing of
all
till the age of maybe 32 or 33 when i
started comedy
you know something came out this week
that was really weird
that i had a feeling about nothing i'm
not gonna sit here and tell you i had a
feeling about but
if i heard it it wouldn't have shocked
me
well wednesday morning i woke up and
they said that
um
tmz reported that chris cornell had
needle marks
on his own
you know his wife said he was slurring
you know he went up to detroit
they got that heroin up there that's
killing [ __ ] you know uh
maybe he was on the road for a few days
you know remember you have to get
highway three days in a row on heroin to
get hooked
i didn't know that yeah it took a couple
days or something like that i don't know
what the real number is and maybe he had
hit that number or he had a few days in
a row and now
you know you never know i don't know but
i was thinking about my behavior at the
time that i went to prison and for two
or three years after i got out of prison
and it was years even after that
and it was that every time things got
good
i put a roadblock upon myself and [ __ ]
them up
like every time i was on the road to
something good
i would [ __ ] myself up
you know it's like a it's a continuing
inner thing that people have
that they don't even know they're doing
they don't even know they don't they
just do something to [ __ ] it up
and when somebody gives you an
opportunity for three weeks you're good
and then one week you snap and you [ __ ]
it up you crash the car you go to jail
you know
heroin seems like the one that like just
it doesn't matter again like i was just
thinking of philip seymour hoffman
like that it just
these people like i don't know you don't
assume that the the people the stars of
of the movies and and the biggest singer
ever or one of them is going to be on
heroin it just doesn't seem i don't know
because i think what you're saying how
like when you growing up musicians want
heroin
i don't know as many or today you don't
think i don't think
you know there's a lot of explanations
as people are just misguided
and then there's people who really have
a pain
and listen
nobody more than me
understands that pain
but you don't want to chase your to
chase that pain your whole life
like i was [ __ ] hooked on coke man i
had a [ __ ] bad problem
you know
and why i'm saying this is because my
mind was hooked okay and for people who
listen to the podcast and know what i'm
talking about you understand when your
mind is hooked
when 65 of your thought process
it's about getting high or who you're
going to get high with or what broad
you're going to take home and eat her
ass when you got coke rocks and
it's just ridiculous it's just
ridiculous but that's what i mean
was i doing in the daytime no was i
doing it before comedy shows no
but at night i was five nights a week i
didn't know how much i was gonna do it
was always a different number some
nights i'd do a gram and go to bed
but i never really had control of it
i i you know i wanted to [ __ ] stop
i stopped i don't know how there's a
thousand [ __ ] explanations
but
right now i'm gonna be sober from
cocaine 10 years
and look at all the good things that
have happened in 10 years
if it wasn't for mercy i think in like
three years i would go on the road one
night meet some chicken do a couple
lines and [ __ ] end up [ __ ] jacked
up no you think yeah yeah yeah i know
for a fact because it's human nature
it's human nature not that i've ever
thought i have this animal controlled i
don't even think about it that way
when i gave up cocaine i gave up cocaine
i gave up cocaine i gave up everything
that came with it i gave it up there's
no itching for it there's no what would
it be like if i went to a bar and got a
package i just don't have that thought
there's only one person who can make me
relapse and that's kate quigley and even
then i'd think twice
if kate quigley put a coke rock in her
[ __ ] i'd have to [ __ ] play dice
you'd have to call her your sponsor i'd
have to roll the dice one time
no um it's just weird that i don't even
think that way like but there's people
so everything was going great for chris
cornell
everything was going great a family a
a great music career
his artistry level was at an all-time
[ __ ] high
you know
i used to you know i saw this
documentary one time about sam kennison
the explanation they had was
that you're so high when you get on
stage
that you still want that high
that's why you continue to [ __ ] do
drugs
you know
with philip seymour hoffman and all
those guys listen
you live right there in the east village
wherever the [ __ ] you living in new york
and that [ __ ] surrounds that area
you know i i when louis gomez was here
the other night i spoke about heroin he
looked at me in shock
as a child i was always very scared
heroin
i grew up with a personal connection to
hate [ __ ] heroin
for some reason or another so
to me it was something that you shot in
your body that i really wanted nothing
to do with
and can't even imagine the needle part
of it and then over the [ __ ] years
um
you know once
once i snorted thc crystal
aka angel dust
i broke that i broke my moral code that
i had with myself
it was okay to do acid it was okay to do
mescaline
it was okay to smoke pot it was okay to
drink
but i was gonna put nothing on my nose
once i put t-a-t crystal up my nose when
i was 15 years old i broke my spirit
like that broke that spirit
even though i hated cocaine cocaine was
gonna follow
my mother died maybe a week or two after
i tried cocaine
the funny thing is when i was sick
yesterday i was forced to watch tv okay
and i realized how bad different tv was
but i watched the last 24 hours
of whitney houston's daughter
you know the the autopsy
and i was thinking about what they were
saying and listen
uh when you
when your mother is the biggest thing in
the world to you which mothers always
are never mind her being whitney houston
and taking you around the world and
uh and that sibling dies you have a huge
hole in your soul
for years and for
there's a little time period deep in
your psyche
that you
you wish you were dead
the biggest thing in your life is dead
how do i know from personal experience
you know when i was 17 i went to a party
and i ate some quaaludes and drank and
snorted some coke and i really [ __ ]
went deep
the people woke me up and they couldn't
they kept thinking they were going to
call the ambulance you know
and i always think of that that specific
night how
i woke up from that night i go maybe i
was telling myself a message because at
that time in my life
i was living my life i was enjoying
myself around my friends
but i was [ __ ] hurting man i was
[ __ ] hurting same thing with chris
cornell it's always the outside looks
great i was hurt i mean i was dying
inside
by that time i was going home at night
and before i would go to where i was
staying i would walk up to my old house
and just look at the windows and see if
maybe she went home and
she didn't call me you know it was just
a psychological [ __ ] fight that i was
doing nobody understands unless you've
been through this you know
so i was
looking at this [ __ ] whitney
houston's daughter and i'm like jesus
christ i was there you know i had that
hole in my heart
i'm just very lucky that
you know i didn't but
you know one of the best times in my
life was
one of the best and worst times in my
life
was after my mother died the best well
i got to really experience people
i learned i was learning something that
most people don't learn to their
way out of high school and maybe in
college
and when my mother died i started
experiencing people
you know at the lowest common
denominator like these were people that
uh
were my friends and now they've become
my brothers
and i was having a great time hanging
out with dede contero at that time at
that time
you know it started at school
and we walked home together or he went
to wrestling practice and i went home
and hung out and did what i did and put
money together
to get a package that night and i team
up with him about 7 7 30
and we [ __ ] go out and do something
mischievous every night
we always listen three four nights a
week me and him made money
at 15 at 15 and he was maybe 14. when i
was 16 maybe he was 14. did he both have
chefs at the local grocery store no no
no nobody had a job here either
we would do whatever we could we would
help his brother with a [ __ ]
stealing tires we would you know we did
something we looked out for the devil
you know we would go do something with
mike denny and we'd look out down by the
ships
me and him always did [ __ ] something
you were a lookout duo like you would be
like a team like a team and he didn't
give a [ __ ] he did anything
we were robbing freaky freddy we were
[ __ ] we were robbing jay haring son
of [ __ ] cans of tomato paste and
selling them for the small nickel like
20 for the case it was 80 brand new i
mean you know but listen five cases a
hundred [ __ ] bucks
that that was a gram of coke
and [ __ ] a six-pack in those days
do you understand man we could do that
every day at that age so you could go to
your one of your neighbor's houses and
knock on the door and be like hey
mrs
no no until we have tomato paste no no
jay horn's son
was down the corner from herman the
sprig store
all right
herman and his wife brandon bodega he
used to make cuban steak sandwiches out
of there all day long on the grill in
1975.
but i in 1979 i would go to jay haren's
son and i had worked at jr and said
i worked at j heinerson for like six
months jay horn's son was a
a warehouse and half of it was frozen
and then i worked on that white rose for
a while white rose it was all frozen
frozen food frozen foods
how much ice cream did you steal
none damn seafood [ __ ] okay why take
the ice cream when you got the lobster
tails in the backseat
the how much a jew goes for the [ __ ]
amateur [ __ ] why take pennies and you
could take dollars
fair enough i didn't know the rest of
you there was two of them that i was
aware of there was jay harmon's son
which was in north bergen new jersey and
that was i started i started there
uh my sophomore year
i didn't play football i was going to
play basketball and there was an opening
then they paid
6.50 an hour
and it was just picking orders and then
loading them on a truck
it was me louis [ __ ] dave dave ruiz
chucky mcbreen it was a whole mckinley
we all went there after school and they
signed all of us
like my whole little crew from mckinley
because we all live close today
and i'll never forget that i had a crew
of 15 year old loading trucks
oh it was a bunch of us with two and
they had two brothers gary and something
else
and it was me john bender a bunch of us
worked at gary haran's son
and i'll never forget that one afternoon
i went there stoned
and i had a what's these things when you
push them uh a hand cart yeah you hang a
handcart what you do is you go up to the
boxes
and you pull the boxes out and then you
pull the boxes over and put the hand
cart in right and you'd push it to the
trucks
and then there'd be somebody right there
in the truck and they'd hold on to the
thing while you pulled the hand cut
fair enough yeah so you could get it out
with the box as well to get out with the
boxes so i would i would load the truck
so they go go get you know 10 cases of
uh tomato paste or 10 cases of whatever
it was all restaurant supplies but in
metal
things you know like these things there
was four in a case okay so do you
understand me they would have all this
in cases and then they would have the
freezer thing where you needed clearance
to go in there that's where your fried
shrimper
that's where all those little foods you
like were oh the dumplings the dumplings
all that type of [ __ ] were in there
so one day it's about we used to work
four to nine
that's it
five hours when you're in [ __ ] high
school yeah i guess when you're lifting
stuff too it's gonna be hard work so
[ __ ] 30 times five that's 150 a
[ __ ] week that's 600 a month you were
living like a doctor in high school
off of that money i lasted like i don't
know a couple days that's
that's
that's that's when i was spitting blood
they put me in the hospital
but let me get to my [ __ ] story here
i'm taking this the card in i got the
four cases or whatever that's heavy
i'm pulling i'm pushing it to the truck
boom i hit the lump
i get on the truck
the guy comes over in this case it's
louis hernandez aka louis the [ __ ] he
comes over i put the cart down
and we can't get the thing i'll never
forget this louie had an afro
so louie put his
louie went to pull the cart
and he had his head in the thing and the
cases fell back
and the cart and his head got stuck but
here's the beauty when i got louie out
of there
you could see the imprint in his afro
from where the metal had gone through
all the way
so his afro was from here from his ear
to maybe on top of his ear and then it
was like
three inches it was [ __ ] classic you
couldn't write this he looked at me and
said what happened i've been
the thing just locked i mean it was i
thought he was dead jesus he lived
i laughed because you know me i'm a sick
[ __ ] it's amazing that this place ever
recovered from having you guys work
there all those those guys worked there
for years i went into the hospital and
then when i got back my job was filled
so i got pissed off but i knew
that they did something weird they would
stop the the
the the
the morning people
if they ran out of work they would stop
the dock
with early orders
so when the truck pulled up
all they had to do was roll those in
and already had the paperwork on the
board right next to the truck
so i knew this so i knew that if you
went there 132 oh my gosh there was
always cases on the thing
me and dede used to cause havoc in that
name but do you understand me
we know all the inn's announced all the
places did you ever steal like an entire
restaurant's order for the day like
how how much did he take i don't know
only i don't know in those days it was
like fresh produce and [ __ ] we would
clip two three boxes and we run him
right up the corner to this pick store
he would give us an envelope we'd throw
in throwing two steak sandwiches and two
sodas
and that was it and we took that money
and we ran that was our own private
neighborhood there
there was a couple drug dealers we
nailed
there was uh an appliance store that we
had clipped one time
because they looked they left their
[ __ ] warehouse [ __ ] in the back how
dare they all those little businesses
were always in danger around that 15
years old you were like a duo of death
there was a guy that would give us money
to bring him sawdust every week what
because he had a transmission shot
he'd give us 50 a week not only did we
steal but we hustled too where do you
buy what do you steal sawdust from
columbia yard
we go to lumber yard just telling we
want [ __ ] sawdust
come on lee you got to be [ __ ]
creative here but that's what me and him
did
him and i i don't know how he did it
till this day no car no car
everything was done on foot
everything was done on foot how we were
kids don't even [ __ ] ask me
but the classic story was
it was the summer
of 80.
it was the summer of 1980
it's [ __ ] hotter than hell
me and dede are hanging out
and you know what by the summer of 80
the realization that my mother was dead
it was now a realization it was like
nine or ten months
and every night the sadness would come
over me a little bit more every night
you know like just in a weird way
and one of the stories i told on the
on ari
which turned out to be a funny story and
some people got pissed off at me
but it was a very true story was that
you know like me and dede were this team
that we hustled so much
in those days we weren't really like
house burglars at all we never would
even dream of robbing somebody's house
but if there was a drug guy we would rob
the house or try to pull something kinky
but like i said me and dede always had
our eyes open
and when they were walking down the
[ __ ] street dog
walking down the [ __ ] street
and right there like you can't like
we're like what are we gonna do for cash
i don't [ __ ] know what do you think i
don't know and also i'm like what is
that crate right there
and we just walked up to it like it
could have been anybody's crate we just
walked up to it and there was like an
ottoman in there whatever people call
that autobahn autobahn like a chair
no no no no like a thing that you put
dishes in and [ __ ] oh okay i'm more or
something i'm warm whatever the [ __ ] it
is
and there was no bottom piece for it
and me and he looked at him like what
the [ __ ] this is nice
and we're like who the [ __ ] would buy
this what are we gonna do with it
where are we gonna take this do we take
this back to the benders
do we take this to your house i mean
either way we're [ __ ] hoofing
it's a three block walk either [ __ ]
way
and i look up the [ __ ] corner and
that dude
gunther brown lives there
and this was
right down the block we found this in
the alleyway of jay harmon's son pretty
much
like that was a truck area
and it just fell off the truck like no
no that was also a place where they did
elevators
like an elevator tool and die company
was there or some [ __ ] when we were
growing up
we never robbed them they had nothing
wrong we didn't know what the [ __ ] a
tool or die was
so
uh
we found this thing and i go what the
[ __ ] am i gonna do with this and it was
the block where the denny's lived and
the [ __ ]
mcneils and the [ __ ] garcias and
and the jansens and all these families
lived on this block and i'm like what
the [ __ ] am i gonna do with this thing
they go dd i got it let's take it to
gunther's house cause gunther collected
beetle stuff
all right so we [ __ ] picked this
thing up
we walk it like 50 yards
it's [ __ ] humid it's hot
like that's that's what made me remember
this because it's it i was sweating
i'll never forget we went to gunther's
house he opens the door with his [ __ ]
robe on
you know higher than [ __ ] and he's like
what's up guys i'm like duncan we know
you're a beatle fan we hate to bother
body
we know that you look for stuff all the
time we like to sell you this and he's
like where the [ __ ] did you guys get
this [ __ ] by that time we just took it
out of the crate and just started
walking with it down the street like we
were moving men
and no one was like hey where do these
teenagers not one person oh we walked at
the gunters
we went up and he goes i'll take it for
sure what are you guys looking to get
i'm like a hundred he's like 80.
and then we're like done
couldn't even been 60 we're like done we
don't give a [ __ ] this just gets us a
half a gram of coke that's all we're
looking to get
a half a gram of coke we put the beer
together we'll get the weed together
we can do a half a gram of coke for 50
[ __ ] bucks the only problem was it
was the afternoon gunther's like i got
something going on here can you come
back at about seven o'clock at night
and i'm like yeah we'll come back it was
nothing on that wheel just one ears
it goes you come back
no offense deity i go no no offense then
and that was it
me and did he hung out the rest of the
day and that night i went to gunther's
browns house
i went over there he invites me in he
still has the robe on he's drinking
first off he this is chick and she's
[ __ ] got to be 60.
she's all beat up on heroin and he's
telling me if you go to the bathroom and
take a [ __ ]
she loves to blow guys when she's
when you're on the toilet that's the
thing and i was like no no no no oh
thank you i go gee man i'm cool
just let me get the cash
and let me go to dd's in those days lee
it was 1980
when somebody offered you a line of
cocaine right you took it
there was no hands it's
butts about it everybody was such a dead
beat for cocaine those days
that anybody who did give you a line
you took it
it could be two in the afternoon it
could be eight in the morning
it could be eleven o'clock at night in
1980 when somebody offered you a bump
you took it because if you went
to somebody and said you're not going to
believe what happened
steve simone offered me a bump the other
night everybody in the room was going to
go you [ __ ] [ __ ] you had a chance
to do coke it was 1980.
nobody really knew what it was so
everybody wanted to do it but nobody had
the hundred dollars to pay for it
okay you're following me
so you're going to say yes so you said
all the rules go out the window all your
rules go out the window in 1980 so i go
[ __ ] yeah at that time i did coke
i do a line of coke he offers me a drink
i got nah i gotta go how old is going to
roam
at this time gunther's probably 33 34.
he's got a robot he listens to the
guitar player from black sabbath he's
got the same mustache
the same type of devilish hair
and then he put music on
like i don't know what the first song
was he put on
but then in the middle of all this
endless love
i don't know what the [ __ ] he put on he
put on like he was like a beetle fan
and then in the middle of all this
he goes [ __ ] it
and
he goes have you ever done heroin
and right there like my heart stopped
like i didn't want to do heroin but i
wanted to do it oh jesus like at that
point
in my life i don't know i was sad
deep down inside i had a job i had money
i was having a fun time but i missed my
mother
this [ __ ] of living with people and
stuff as nice as the benders were
it was just rough on me so i said you
know what gunther brown
give me a lot of that [ __ ]
even then you you wouldn't do the needle
no no at that point
a needle in the room
i wouldn't even stick around at least
now i stick around i just looked the
other way
it's like ranch on the table for you
yeah i just turned around in those days
a needle i couldn't even deal with it
[ __ ] okay a needle i couldn't even deal
with it so yeah
he offered you he was he was snorting
too okay he was snorting it too
so that was it i i did a little he goes
do one see what you think and then do
another one i'll never forget he looked
at me goes and if you get sick run to
the bathroom i go sick
i was like least i gotta go why would i
get sick
yeah that's uh
like when you were saying you gave you
sold it just for a gram of coke it made
me think about like it was essentially a
pawn shop like a pawn shop deal
and it's sad that like people are so
willing
to give up like 60 of what it's worth
just to get like just because i know
that'll get them some drugs no no no no
see on the east coast in certain
neighborhoods everybody knows
that there's a guy in the neighborhood
and it wasn't me i'm just saying okay
gotcha everybody knows that there's a
guy in the neighborhood
that can help you out with stuff if you
need a tv if you need a washer dryer
every neighborhood in the east coast has
them from boston
all the way down to [ __ ] philadelphia
okay there's a guy that knows a guy that
knows a guy
and what that means is
that you know what maybe you get
something 50 percent off
in a box
you just can't send in the warranty no
no i'm i'm talking about like if you
were gonna go sell that washer dryer and
they're like we'll give you 50 bucks for
it and it's worth 400 or whatever it is
no no no but what you do is you already
know it's it's 200 going in
like i don't know what that thing was
worth we just walked down the street and
bumped into it
you know what i'm saying i just bumped
into 60 100 bucks if you think i'm gonna
walk the thing home and then take the
numbers off it and call around and get
the retail price
in those days there wasn't enter that
way
so it wasn't that easy to look prices up
and to [ __ ] it and see what so you just
got what you could there was plenty of
times i went to pawn shops
and things like that now
you know when i was scamming
jewelry was
800 an ounce in 1980 check it and see
for gold for gold it was 800 an ounce
850 an ounce
what the weight for gold was in 1980
80.
uh
yearly high was
850 and low is 474. what the [ __ ] you
think you're dealing with 1980 when it
was 850 oh my god and look at this 77
168 was the high
and 79 it was 524 jumped
in 1982 what was it let's see here
in 1982 and went down a little bit to
488 480
and then 84.
84 went down to 4 85 it went down to
340.
but then it started going up
uh oh my
god in the last the last one on this
charts 2015 and it's up to 1300 and now
1300 yeah
now you show up with a little [ __ ]
ring they give you 500.
[ __ ] my dad was buying uh wasn't gold he
would buy quarters like
for the silver like we had barrels of
quarters in our ba in our basement for a
little bit because if they're made
before a certain time they have
like a hundred made with mostly silver
so it like it
is that how much of your money was with
gold
me yeah
in those days i worked at randall lumber
and there was a guy named boji
who was a half a gangster and his day
job was to buy gold he got he got their
owner richie werderman who was a crooked
guy to give him a stand in there
and he would buy gold and i talked to
him and he would tell me listen if
you're going to sell something this is
the time
so i had friends who had friends who had
friends and you know whenever something
they needed to be sold and there was no
paperwork on it
i slipped it to mr bulgey but the most
interesting thing was one time i found a
[ __ ] penny
in a drill
and i put it in my pocket like you know
when you put change in the drill and
then you go back and take the change out
you look through the change and there
was like a weird penny
and one time a miranda alum when i give
him the penny of mr boyd jonathan mr
mojo what type of pen is this he goes
hold on one second
and he gave it back it was worth 480.
he goes you want it yeah he gave me 408
jesus christ like [ __ ] like that was
happening in 82. was tony better that
dammit
i thought you were looking at the sugar
cubes
[Music]
wow
that last rattle wasn't water
we just had a few more stars out of
respect for memorial day
it's a 10 star [ __ ] salute here on
the church of what's happening now
these are the 125 so don't get excited
you know we could eat 35 of these things
and not blink a [ __ ] eye you
understand me i'll never blink again
it's funny this weekend i watched uh
i'm telling you man being sick isn't fun
but i couldn't even focus on the
internet
excuse me i couldn't focus on writing
i really couldn't focus on anything
except sitting there and
shaking and then two minutes late i'd be
[ __ ] sweating then i'd be shaking
but i watched viceland one night
i watched an interesting one
about sugar daddies and it was crazy
because i was breaking becky's balls
you're obsessed with this topic
you know it was just odd yeah you know
it was just on i don't know i'm judging
you i'm just it's just you're very
interested in it it's no no we were just
talking about it the one night
and it's just it made me think because i
dated a girl who went through that
and i thought about they showed the girl
having the conversation
with a guy online
and by that guy talking
i remembered how creepy
my ex's
sugar daddy was uh you met him
oh yeah we have a half a fist fight
but before that we used to talk on the
phone
and i could i would say to her how old
is this guy
and she would say 50 something
and i go doesn't this guy have kids no
doesn't
hasn't he been married no you know what
does he do
and she goes he gets money from his
family
and he just hires women
that's it and he goes i was one of the
women that
he put me through school
what
so i'm watching this show
and i
i was breaking becky's balls one day
about it becky doesn't have a boyfriend
she's fighting for her life
so i'm like becca you're a good looking
chick get yourself an old guy and lick
his balls once a month and get the small
nickel or the small g note have them pay
your rent and car payment you move on
your [ __ ] way right
i didn't i forgot how creepy it was
and i forgot the guys that do it how
creepy they are i forgot
i [ __ ]
forgot what are they like
i can't like just that first so you go
to some website approach
you sign up
and then you do like a skype
and the guy talks to you on skype he
makes you get up and show them your body
now i thought it was the illusion and
this is what they were examining on
advice land
that
the illusion was that a guy calls you up
and
says gonna pay you five grand a month
i'm gonna come over and let your [ __ ]
on fire four times a month
as a matter of fact take the pill and
not have your period
you know what i'm saying because you
don't know when i'm coming over i'm
dropping over like a [ __ ] marine an
apocalypse now
you don't know when the [ __ ] i'm showing
up
but no
this place makes you pay by the move
so if you go on a date with the guy and
you want to [ __ ]
it's like a flat you know 600 or
whatever
and the two girls they talked to weren't
that attractive
but they were freaks
i i don't know i didn't really ask about
their personal sexual preferences
these girls just wanted to be taken care
of
now what
do you have anything do you know
anything about russian brides i've
always heard about that they're here
it's [ __ ] crazy because when i first
moved here
one of the guys that took care of my
comedy had a russian bride
so they're real like you can actually
like get a mail order brian yeah oh
i don't know how he got his
i can't really [ __ ] spell it out how
he got his okay i know he didn't get his
true line because they they like they
used him he met somebody he sold his
company
and got a ton of [ __ ] money
and had a ton of money to burn and i
guess the year before he had gone to
russia
and i saw the russian women
and he [ __ ] uh
he uh went on he
he go he went to this guy here and the
guy showed him pictures oh my god and he
paid and they they flew the girl here
and he married it made her a citizen
and then she had big tits
guess what she did
she divorced him and made her tits even
bigger
and then about two years later this went
down in 97 98 doesn't work anymore
and then i stopped working with the guy
and then i saw her in like 2004
and her tit were like past pornographic
bait
like she made him so big
it was just absurd like when she was
around you felt uncomfortable
and in hollywood you even felt more
uncomfortable
and she was a good looking woman but
nobody has that tits that big
and she showed up at the lab factory
with a different guy and he had to be
like [ __ ] 70.
meanwhile she's like 35.
that
i don't mean that like no i don't know i
don't know who schedules them
i don't know anything about it so don't
you know no but that's just a whole new
thing like i guess it's not new
just
women being able to they live their
whole lives just based off of their
looks
which i mean i would do if i was a hot
girl but
it seemed it seems like a weird way to
live your life
like always be getting stuff from people
hey listen we're the ones that give them
this stuff
right absolutely
we're the ones that give them the style
so but i know i feel weird sometimes
when people try to give me things i
wonder if they have that uh
at all if they're if it's just so
ingrained in them
no i feel the same way you know i feel
the same way when people give you stuff
sometimes you don't know how to accept
it
i think whitney cummings had a whole
story on that or a whole blog on that
like she felt really insecure about it
i think as a woman
i mean i'm not a woman i'm not a [ __ ]
woman so i don't know where they even
start
it wouldn't even be for me to say this
but
if i'm around a woman i don't mind
paying for it
i feel like i don't ought to
that's just me
we i i was talking about groupon at the
beginning but i had a thing
when i was dating like that it made me
uncomfortable to have girls pay
and and now this is the first like real
relationship where someone has been paid
but it took a while it's weird like the
first
i don't know i like the especially the
first date you feel like you have to pay
i mean i'm sure in every relationship
not everybody's [ __ ] theodore
roosevelt walking around with a bag full
of [ __ ] 50s in the beginning
and after you guys settle in and explain
to your girlfriend your situation she
understands you
that's where the love and trust begins
when she says you know what i don't care
if you make 300 a week i still want to
marry you you know i want to help you go
to school and be a better yourself or
become a cop
that's what those early relationships
are about women who stick it out with
you from the beginning
you know
so everybody has that
it's the guy that tells the wife and
strings her along that he's a
millionaire
then marries her and he makes this whole
thing a house she can't see his books
no you got to be honest right now
you know i mean that's one of the white
lies you'll never get out of it's about
telling them that you're something that
you're not in that sense i was a dentist
nah
i'm really a dental assistant
you know
that like that i don't that's a whole
nother
thing i don't understand is how someone
could do something
it happens all the time like like
finally find out that the principal gets
fired because they they fake their their
resume or just something weird like i
don't understand how people could could
do that and i mean i guess before the
internet you could get away with it but
not now i faked my resume for 15 years
but it wasn't for
high-level jobs no
no
could i have done it and maybe got away
with it
yeah
because you got to assume they don't
check
you have to assume they don't check
i've never had you have to assume maybe
they'll call a personal reference
okay yeah but i mean
won't when your friend know or what do
you have to tell before you pull like
the george costanza and like tell your
friend to be like yeah i know how to
drive a forklift or
yeah i know how to like did you ever lie
like that like yeah i have this
certification or
i think i lied once or twice when it
came to work
but if you look somebody in the eye and
you go listen bro i don't know how to do
that but i'm willing to learn oh yeah
yeah they love it they love it so that's
how i overcame that stuff i i used to
drive a [ __ ] high low man
that's crazy is that a forklift a
forklift okay
and i used to put pallets on trucks and
i would bang into shoes
i was [ __ ] terrible
and then i almost got put on like i
almost got up
i almost became a high low guy for a
masonry company i worked with them for a
while they were like won't you
and i thought about then i got another
job
where you had a shovel snow and a high
low
in colorado remember i told you the
people would come and i wouldn't come
out of the house i'd be so cooked up i
wouldn't leave the house and then
finally they fired me i got my [ __ ]
jimmy membership yanked
but you have to sit in a in a
uh whatever it is a hilo and plow the
streets plow the streets and it has like
it's called something else like a snow
thing and it has like the bottom is that
of a
tank like a tank the way that wheels
spin around right like that
it's not even with tires
but i drove all those i can't believe i
did
i couldn't believe myself today i still
did no one ever trusted me with that
stuff
i worked hard so i didn't mind getting
behind something learning how to [ __ ]
do it
that's why i always look at all these
construction sites as i drive by look at
the masonry work
i love to look at the scaffolding i love
to look at the masonry work and see how
they [ __ ]
are putting up the mace every time i see
pokemon
every time i see people laborers putting
up
scaffolds i [ __ ] my pants i stop what
i'm doing for 10 minutes i just watch
them
it's the most interesting thing
it's the most interesting thing i ever
did i didn't have the balls to go on top
of the third floor
like once they made me do the third
floor that's when i said hold on we're
saying i gotta get something out of my
car
you couldn't just do this
the first three floors on all sides oh
my god it was after the third floor
that's it i can't put a scaffold up
i can't be up there hanging like a
monkey would they will they give you
something to walk into
listen i don't remember
all i know is you hang up the first two
pieces you put those [ __ ] things in
the things that you open up and then you
click onto the sides and you screw those
in
then you put a pipe across and then you
keep doing that
you keep doing the first level and then
somebody gets up there and starts
putting down two by tens
or two by twelve boards two by twelve
two by two by twelve twelves so it's 2
by 12 inches
12 feet and you just put them down
and also when you climb on top of those
and somebody starts handing you those
and you start putting those just like
that
and then you put those crossbars in them
tick tick tick tick tick tick tick tick
tick tick and then you do that all the
way down and then again the two by
twelves and then you [ __ ] that right
there was when i said no no no no no
i could do the first two levels of two
by twelves
one time i built the scaffold with a
dude that was like [ __ ] 65
when i was 20 okay and 65 guys is
conservative don't ask me what his name
was don't i don't know nothing
i worked for him for maybe four months
and it was one of the best jobs i ever
had he was one of the best bosses in the
world because
you know he would tell me that he needed
these things
and i would do them for him and i would
check on him every 10 minutes he was
[ __ ] 60 something 70 years old
he wouldn't even be anywhere close to
the speed
that i was but
his workmanship
he had been doing it so lonely his
people hired him because of his
workmanship
he would sit there all day with [ __ ]
different machines and do [ __ ]
and i learned a lot of those things from
him
but the first week of working with him
we had to build a scaffold
and he broke my rib
what oh yeah he was a beast this guy he
was six foot four he threw that piece of
wood up
and clipping in the rib on the way up
he drove me to the hospital he gave me a
200 raise
not a bad deal no but he built a
three-story scaffold from wood no metal
what
would oh my god
you don't know what [ __ ] in your [ __ ]
pants is and he was built he was sending
me the wood up
climbing up there on the ladder and
helped me [ __ ] put it down it was
just me and him that day what do you
reuse at every site or what do you no
there was only one we only did one job
together
we had to remodel the outside of four
condos and their balconies
that was it and it took us 14 months
and it was tongue and groove wood
like a cider that we had put in and it
was tongue and groove but he added some
stuff to it and that's what man we took
i took the job like in august and we
went all the way to christmas eve
and he gave me a bonus and everything he
was a good dude
when i robbed the jewelry store i used
that apartment as my cover
when i tried to rob this jewelry store
in [ __ ] snowmass village i used that
up i used those apartment buildings
is where i had my tools and the change
of clothing and all that stuff
i had a broom outside so i could sweep
all four [ __ ] things
it was amazing that's what i used and i
went in there and changed and then
walked out the front door
and they if the cops stopped me and
asked me what was i doing there i went
up there to plug the
because it was true i used to have to go
up there on sunday nights
and plug the [ __ ] uh
the computer no there was something i
had to plug in
oh the generator i had to plug the
generator and on sunday nights with the
charge up for monday morning
[ __ ]
that's what it was
so i was going to use that as my excuse
i had to go play and charge the [ __ ]
generator let me give you some shout
outs yeah i didn't give some shout outs
wrap this [ __ ] well you know him
yeah yeah that's what i use that [ __ ]
apartment i just remembered that jesus
christ
minutes with marcan
hands down sports pablo castro
trapper welton lj meg 715
locomotive and meet the the courts
like i told you [ __ ] in the
beginning don't forget i'll be at
flappers thursday night
7 30 working out with uncle joey's
series
this weekend it said flappers
uh and the next thursday i'm at [ __ ]
the brand prop thursday friday saturday
oh [ __ ] where this whole movement
started on wednesday nights the second
wednesday of the
month we used to do dirty night
hosted by joey diaz at the brea improv
and that's how this whole [ __ ]
movement started so put that in your
pipe and smoking [ __ ] indeed that you
were the priest was there we did the
year the priesthood that's right yeah
yeah yeah a lot of a lot of history of
bray improv so if you're not doing
anything next weekend
the uh eighth through the tenth i think
come on down [ __ ] okay i'll be there
eating stars it'll be fun yeah you'll be
captain [ __ ] stars yeah yeah i forgot
all about that [ __ ] apartment i've
had some interesting jobs man
i was 19 when i had that job and we did
everything by hand
everything and i didn't know dick i
would just hand him the wood
i would get lunch
i would sweep i'd pick up the [ __ ]
wood parts at the end of the day
i'd empty the trash and was it his
business or was it was his business
and he worked by himself and i had just
come from quitting a job
and i was walking and he pulled over
hey man
i'm looking for a helper reconstruction
you know anybody
i know what kind of construction he told
me basic carpentry we're building a
scaffold. start you at this i forgot it
was on good salary i go yeah he goes be
there tomorrow i'll try you out for two
days
[ __ ]
after the two days he told me to stick
around he told me to buy tools
what tools to buy
i know we you've talked about how
sometimes it would freak you out to
think about doing some to your 65.
was that was there one or two of them
that you think you could have done
i was hoping that
i would have taken to one form of
construction
i like the construction lifestyle if
it's done
correctly and what i wanted to do with
it
like at first i wanted to be a mason
i wanted to work for somebody for six or
seven years
was to teach me how to be a [ __ ]
mason
teach me to make the cement teach me how
to lay the brick
teach me how to lay commercial brick
just teach me everything to know
about me sorry about masonry i'd work 60
hours and let you pay me for 40.
well i'd be one of those guys that's my
loyalty for you to teach me
so once my job is done as a hot carrier
i get off my [ __ ] job
and i get on the line i lay brick with
you and help you out you know that was
always my [ __ ] dream you know
and then after eight years you learn the
[ __ ] you want to do which is fireplaces
and
you know you want to take little chances
and other different places uh
little walks and you just want to be
busy doing that stuff i could have done
that a different life i think
and you have to sell see that's the
beauty of it that i could have sold
i don't mind knocking on somebody's door
ma'am
my name is [ __ ] uh
you know joey diaz and i own a
construction company and i saw these
stairs
aren't good here i think i could write
you an estimate for maybe a hundred
dollars that's two days worth
you know you could put those together
two two three of those a week
because even if you do that for 100
bucks and you take a garbage out she's
like oh you know my husband died i need
you to do the steps in the back
can you do it for 600 and now you have
work and now guess what she tells her
friend
at bingo that you did it and that's how
you become a businessman
i think do you think there's a negative
like people look down people who do drop
like that hold your jobs like what
construction
cement listen man nobody looks down on
anybody for working
as an american a legit person
they should be shot and [ __ ] hung
when i think of work people when i go to
mcdonald's
all right with mercy right there's a
spanish woman who's always there
with a huge diamond ring around her
finger
she's attractive
you know she you could tell she's been
at mcdonald's for a few years you know
i'm saying
i can look at her in a [ __ ] up way or
anybody in that kitchen
but what type of person would i be i got
to look at them as a type of person
they're [ __ ] working
they're working even if they're
ex-comics
they're working
they're keeping it together they're
working at mcdonald's
they didn't have that much [ __ ] pride
you know what i'm saying you can't eat
pride
you cannot eat pride
and not at every american no no you are
right people do look down at mcdonald's
jobs because they're always hiring
aren't they
yeah every movie theater there's a guy
who i love he's one of my best friends
he has a master's degree
but he stayed at the movie theater and
he's now he's the general manager of one
of the biggest of the biggest theater in
the state
uh so he's making good money now but i
can't we we've talked about how he like
he
had issues with not pursuing his his
thing
but he
he loved the theater and he chose to
make it a career
i'm staying at the movie theater yeah
and now he's at gm he's probably making
six figures listen you go to college and
while you're at college you get a job
and the pieces come together and also
sudden you got to college you're like
what am i going to look for a job for i
already got a job i've been here for
five years yeah
i know everything they give me a
promotion management and i keep the job
here for a few years until i see what i
really want to [ __ ] do there's
nothing wrong with that listen [ __ ]
nothing wrong with working
especially when you have all the
logistics to work when you don't have a
felony
and all that [ __ ] if you could work man
and keep making money and keep getting
incentives
you know selling [ __ ] or whatever the
[ __ ] it is that you do i never looked
down on anybody because i did some
creepy [ __ ] when i was working i didn't
mind doing it i never let that [ __ ]
bother me i didn't tell everybody i was
doing it as a job
do you know what i'm saying i never you
know there was a lot of jobs like that i
wasn't too proud of
i can't think of right now but you
doomed for a week or two
to get you by and that's it
i would do them for a while like i like
i remember having to like sweep out i
remember one july 4th having to sweep
out a storeroom at a cvs
like the like i but i miss those kind of
jobs too to be honest with you
it's no pressure job you go in there you
get a salary you know what you're going
to walk with
you know for you a guy like you you go
to three or four movies a week don't you
oh my god yeah i work three or four
movies every day every [ __ ] day you
go see a movie so for a guy like you you
think you're getting 200 a week just in
the movies and the razor nets
just in the movie and the reason that
you think you're getting a [ __ ]
bargain well yeah i mean if if
if i could have somehow i think that's
the job if i could have somehow made
like stayed
in being a like a teenager but could
live on what i was making at a movie
theater it was the most fun i ever had
and it just it's uh
and those people are just listening
i had a lot of fun jobs that were fun
but those jobs are usually fun
you pay your rent you make a car payment
yeah and you struggle the rest of the
month
that's a problem with fun jobs and one
day you come to that realization you go
jesus christ my uncle just offered me a
job
doing this for [ __ ] 15 an hour
but i got a job but i get 850 an hour
and it's so much [ __ ] fun
and you know that's what happens and
after two or three years you know
if i want to have fun i gotta skateboard
and
put a blindfold on and go downhill or
something like that i don't [ __ ] know
i can't imagine raising a kid on that
salary because there's people who did
this is one
i always think of her she had like four
kids so there's people who
first off this people make it happen
those are the people i take my [ __ ]
i give my heart to there's people that
make it happen
and
if you leave this
facility right now and you make a right
if you go maybe 40 yards it's a daycare
there's a illegal mexican daycare
in the building over there i didn't know
that okay
if you pull out of here every night
you'll see that there's a car in the
middle of the block always double parked
there's a reason for that because
somebody's picking up their kids
it could be at two in the morning it
could be at four in the morning
there were plenty of nights when i was
driving down here at midnight and i'd
see two parents running out with
a kid put him in the same car in the
back seat like a mom and a dad pick him
they just got off of work you know okay
jesus these are people who have [ __ ]
two two and a half jobs a piece
and this they have to pay the daycare is
like one lady with six kids she takes
them around the corner and just walks
around the corner all day
they hold their hands at the cutest
thing she always waved she's really nice
to the kids
if i was in a bench
i'd have to take mercy over there
you know what can she call i mean she
has to
i think she charges you and the kids
bring their own food
it's not scholastically approved
they're not going to be [ __ ] uh
singing songs learning about the bible
or
you know doing a lot of hearts and crabs
but somebody's watching your kid
there's a lot of families who who do
like the one parent works night shift
one parent works day shift
that i can't imagine doing that
you know uh
i'm very fortunate you know
terry and i struggled for a lot of years
and
now that we have the baby you know
everything's okay and i'm very fortunate
for that that i tell terry i think every
day
i look okay you imagine right now you
have to be
i'd have to be strapping her in the car
to take her to school
and you'd be on the 101 headed [ __ ]
south at 7 30 in the morning
i'd have to pick her up at five bring
her home
start cooking for you to come in the
door at 6 15
to take her
put her in the bath read her a story eat
go to bed to do it over again for the
next four days
and then once a month you'd have to
[ __ ] know twice a month
you'd have to
thursday and friday she's got to pick
the kid up at 5 30 or 6 because i would
be on the road
[ __ ]
yeah what if there were more than one
and if there's a traffic jam my daughter
gets stuck at [ __ ] daycare at six
you know he wouldn't be no no it would
have been a struggle so that's why every
morning
i get up and i'm thankful as [ __ ]
that at this time like i tell perry
listen in the year you never know
in a year this whole thing might be over
and [ __ ] you could run the house you
could go back to work and i'll do what
you got to do here i walk into school in
the morning get the lunch ready and
get the spaghetti going at night
whatever the [ __ ] it is if that's what
it came down to
do you have to be very realistic because
you've gone from
being a rich spoiled kid to homeless
and then back like that's
i've always been very lucky my parents
made a lot less than they used to for a
while and we were we had issues but
i never i never was broke or homeless or
had to move or
listen i was
i was hand to mouth
from 1981
to 2000.
and nine
what do you mean hand to mouth
like weekly
the longest yard bail me out for a while
that just called the alligators off
that didn't do dick
all right all those projects i did on tv
all those years
that just covered the bases the
addiction
some of the child support shoes
you know the daily necessities there was
no cutting off the top there was no
paying off to vic is what i'm trying to
say to you got you okay okay there was
no pain off the vic the
note kept ticking
and i kept running that [ __ ] up
knowing that
eventually
something
something was gonna give
i stopped doing blow in 2007
that immediately freed up two or three
thousand dollars a month
immediately freed up you thought you
were rich so the [ __ ]
so
all those years
you know
all those gigs that i would go home i
would go out at night and pick up two
hundred dollars which is a lot of money
to some people i'd pick up two dollars
yeah i would do four gigs and pick up
two hundred dollars you know 75 here 50
here 50 here
i'd go out on those nights
and i'd come home broke because i bought
weed coke and filled up the gas tank
but now there was no more coke
that was a 60 i was saving
so once i got off the drugs i started
profiting just getting off the drugs
just getting off drugs and staying where
i was doing comedy and [ __ ] around
that was it
and you were making money
that's yeah i was putting away money not
a lot of money i didn't have to call my
wife every day and tell her to put 20 on
my books
so 2008 we both lived off one account
and i would call her every day by
lunchtime and tell her what to put on my
books for the debt
and she would go you [ __ ] how can i
put 40 on your books if we only have 66
like there were those type of days all
right then give me a 20.
i'll figure it out
and i'd put together 20 or 30 on my own
that lasted for years brother
in 2009 with the [ __ ] no drugs for
two years and paying off bills
we saw some daylight that booked a
couple commercials that were lucrative
those commercials really bailed me out
that's why i always say if you live in
l.a go out for commercials
because at that time in my life those
commercials were like hitting the
[ __ ] lottery for me
i can't
i like to think i'm a hard worker but i
don't think
i don't think if i had 66 dollars left i
would be here
i just don't think it would happen 66
dollars till friday oh and i had a gig
on wednesday i had like 150 on thursday
and i had a [ __ ] pick up a check at
the comedy store for 90 bucks on friday
and my wife would get paid every two
weeks
and there was night she was a waitress
and she'd come home we'd have 44 dollars
for the day
and we needed to buy two packs of
cigarettes a piece
and eat and feed the cat fenney
and um and you wouldn't you would see
this and still when you got the money
for the gigs would be like yeah
coke weed and half of what went to my
wife
as long as i had coke and weed i didn't
need money in my pocket i could always
get a free drink at the [ __ ] calorie
store
as long as i had coke and weed
everything else fell into place it's
like a motivational
poster
it's a true [ __ ] story let's wrap
this [ __ ] up here don't forget
thursday night i'm at flappers
and then the following week the 6th
through the 10th i'm at the bread
improv
we ain't [ __ ] around
taking it back old
school listen man i know a lot of you
[ __ ]
are at home you're sitting there you
listen to the podcast you're thinking
about uh
the summer and what you want to do or
whatever
lyft is a ride sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
lyft believes that being a right-sharing
driver should be fun if you're having a
good time so are your passengers correct
so if you're choosing a ride sharing
company to drive for
go with the company that treats you
better
lyft
only lyft driver will only lift offers
in app tipping when you drive for lip
you keep 100 of the tips drivers have
been paid over 150 million tips
since the feature was introduced express
pay lets the drivers get paid almost
instantly instead of waiting for weeks
lifted lyft has even taken the guesswork
out of pickups the new amp device uses
color coding to help passengers find
their drivers you can earn hundreds of
dollars a week listen to me hundreds of
dollars a week plus tips you want to
make more money you drive more it's
never been that easy
so to give yourself a raise it's that
simple you know what i i need to make a
lot of money then you know what start
drinking coffee and get out there it's a
simple formula happy drivers mean happy
passengers
maybe that's why nine out of ten lift
rides get a perfect
five star rating your experiences with
left have been marvelous my experience
has been with lyft have been marvelous
so they do something
it's just a much
friendlier experience it's the nice the
cars are always clean they're friendly
people and then and then when you have
choice that's what you look for so join
the ride-sharing company that believes
in treating its people better go to
lyft.com right now slash joey and i'm
gonna get you a 500
new driver bonus again if you go to
lyft.com
joey today i'm gonna get you a 500
new driver bonus that's lyft.com
joey limited time only terms apply but
let me tell you something if you're just
sitting there and you got a nice car
it's like the man said in the public
greenwich village why i got a fancy suit
for charlie you got no job to wear it to
go to lyft.com
joey number two when i called you
yesterday what did you get from blue
apron oh i got a great box this week we
made a spicy chicken tenders with mashed
potatoes and green beans okay this uh on
a friday night was delicious we i i have
a spicy korean i have spicy korean
chicken with uh mushrooms and roasted
potatoes still at the house and um one
more but it's been my dad made the spicy
korean one yesterday he said it was
delicious
it's uh it was they're they've been on
our roll recently with like really
delicious recipes i've seen them i see
them i mean look at the ones for this
month blue apron you got warm smoked
salmon trout an asparagus salad with
fingerling potatoes and garlic croutons
you got spiced zucchini enchiladas with
creamy lime and tomato rice but listen
not all ingredients are created equal
fresh high quality ingredients
make a real difference so it's important
to know where your food comes from
okay like like lee said he got a great
box sent to him this weekend it tasted
great it was easy to cook he has the
recipe
for less than ten dollars per person per
meal blue apron delivers seasoned
recipes along with proportion
ingredients to make your delicious
home-cooked meal
choose from a variety of new recipes
each week or let blue apron's culinary
team surprise you recipes are not
repeated within a year so you'll never
ever ever get bored
customize your recipes each week based
on your preferences blue apron has
several delivery options so you can
choose what fits your needs and there's
no weekly commitment so you only get the
deliveries that you want when you want
them each meal comes with a step-by-step
easy to follow recipe card proportional
ingredients and can be prepared in 40
minutes or less again 40 minutes or less
blue aprons freshness guarantee promises
that every ingredient in your delivery
arise ready to cook or they'll make it
right this week's menu again
i love style vegetable tostadas with
summer squash poblano peppers and
cilantro rice or peach honey glazed
chicken with mashed sweet potatoes
collard greens and thai basil all right
what are we gonna do i'm gonna get you
three free meals plus free shipping by
going to blueapron.com
joey again i'm going to get your first
three meals for free with free shipping
when you go to blueapron.com joey you'll
love how it feels you'll love how it
tastes and you don't know how great
you'll feel to create your home cook
meals with the people you love around
you with blue apron so don't wait go to
blueapron.com joey i'm going to give you
the first three meals free with three
free shipping blue apron it's a better
way to cook i want to thank my man lisa
but most importantly i want to wish all
you [ __ ] happy memorial day
thank you for listening have a great
week and we'll see you kung suckers
wednesday night stay black
so
[Music]
so
you